joining me now to discuss that report
showing the situation in madagascar
and the world food and hunger profile
elsewhere is the executive director of
the world food programme david beasley
mr beasley if i could ask you first of
all
it's become a sort of headline that
what's happening in madagascar is the
first climate change famine i don't know
if you agree with that and and if you do
agree what does that mean
well adam what what you're talking about
is this is the beginning of many of
these types of
events around the world we're already
seeing mass number of more
hurricanes and droughts and flash
flooding madagascar is the beginning and
this is i mean what you just saw if that
doesn't break your heart nothing will
and so
these people are going to die unless we
do something so while at cop26 people
are working on long-term solutions we've
got to provide short-term solutions so
these people can survive and this is
what i'm most concerned part about right
now because just where she was where
alex was you got 1.3 million people
marching to starvation and adam out of
that 484 000 of those are knocking on
famine's door i was just down there
myself i've seen these children they're
dying right before your very own eyes
and it's only climate related not
conflict not covered climate and climate
alone
and what can be done in the short term
to
alleviate that situation well there are
two things one is we need money and food
to come down there and save their lives
on the immediate spot but number two
we've got resilience programs where we
can come in and water harvest drill
wells holding ponds so that people can
survive until there's long-term
solutions they're either going to die or
they have to migrate there's one of the
two that's the only choices we have on
the immediate term so while the world
developing nations are struggling and
here we have a country of people that
have done nothing to contribute to the
climate crisis and we have a moral
obligation to come down and give them
the tools necessary to put water back
into their lives so they can grow their
own crops take care of themselves
because we just can't start continuing
to send food send food send food we need
short-term solutions as well as
long-term solutions and we've got those
solutions they need to be funded
now this question of of the aid that's
needed to sort out world hunger has
become a bit of a bone of contention on
social media
uh with elon musk
the multi-billionaire
challenging you saying uh that uh
if the world food programme can describe
on this twitter thread exactly how six
billion dollars will solve world hunger
i will sell tesla stock right now and do
it
uh is that what you're saying that uh
six billion could sort out world hunger
and he's got the money
two things i'm so glad that elon's
entered the conversations and i look
forward to getting that check that money
from him because we will prove very
clearly to him that with that six
billion we can save the lives of 42
million people knocking on famine's door
around the world and let me say this
adam it won't just save those lives but
it will also keep nations from being
destabilized and it will keep mass
migration by necessity from happening so
it's a win-win for everybody i mean just
yesterday uh elon's stock went up 21
billion dollars i just need 6 billion of
it
he's got over 300 billion i'm not
picking on elon i want him to make money
but you know with this crisis where one
time crisis we're facing right now
because of covid
we need some help because governments
are tapped out and i need for the
world's wealthiest billionaires to step
up save some lives and show the world
you care because capitalism is good but
you got to share the wealth with people
in need and that time is now i mean
i mean it has to be said if you look at
the
scale of the money that's being talked
about here
for climate change transfers of half a
trillion
or even a trillion dollars from rich
nations to the poor net transfers uh six
billion sounds awfully little
no no adam that's what's amazing there's
400 trillion actually 430 trillion
dollars worth of wealth on earth today
we're just talking about a drop in the
bucket and for example uh just in the
last 12 months in the united states the
top 400 billionaires net worth increase
went up from 2.8 billion to four point
seven two point four point five billion
all we need is point three four percent
that's i said four point three four not
three four point three four percent of
that to solve this problem that we're
facing right now that's not too much to
ask we can do it
and at the program how much
money are you getting
well we have our normal operations which
is between eight and nine billion but
because of the coveted one-time crisis
that we're facing on top of everything
else this is why we need the extra 6
billion for those in that 42 million
people in that what we call ipc ford
knocking on famine's door and so we need
6 billion to reach them over the next 12
months and that's one meal a day at
about 40 43 cents per day and uh we're
not talking about a whole lot of food
but at least will allow them to survive
and make it to the next day
david b is the of the un food program
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you adam